you know who's doing it right your  grandparents because they don't own a  cell phone but on the off chance that  they do they're certainly not blasted  with unimportant text because they don't  know how sure you always have the same  exact conversation about the weather  questions about when you're planning to  get married and or have a child and the  constant updates about your  overachieving cousin Christopher we get  a grandma Christopher is the perfect  human being another kid and the  promotion I'm so happy for him he has  been cheating on Mary for like six years  even though he only talked once a month  that conversation means way more than  the 6,000 plus sup texture receiving  that time I believe it was JK Simmons  who said it best call your grandparents  seriously give him a ring sure they'll  appreciate it if they can hear you it's  John you know who's doing it right my  friend Diana who eloped in Hawaii I  didn't realize she was engaged that I'm  on facebook